Violet, Klaus and Sunny were intelligent children.
Most everything that happened to them was rife with misfortune and despair.
Your parents have perished in a terrible fire.
"Perished" means killed.
We know what perished means.
Hello, hello, hello children.
I am Count Olaf, your new guardian.
You know what this is?
Looks like a list.
Wrong, it's a list!
A list of chores.
We know you're just trying to steal our parents' fortune.
We have to get out of this wretched place.
Go back in the house,...
...where it's safer...
...and strangers can't get you.
Strangers, where?
The Baudelaire children will be destroyed.
What?
When the sand runs out, that fortune is mine.
I didn't realize the sand went so quickly, I bought it online.
You're gonna need to flip it a couple of times.
My name is Captain Sham.
This man is really Count Olaf in disguise.
Aren't you smart?
Wherever you go, I will hunt you down.
Why do you hate us so much?
Because it's fun.
We are setting out on a very top secret expedition.
What do you say, Baudelaires? Are you in?